republican florida representative matt
gates is probably not the wackiest
member of congress or the dumbest member
of congress i think we have to give
those titles to people like marjorie
taylor greene and lauren bobert and
louie gohmert but gates he has to be the
most despicable member of congress right
and there's definitely some supporting
evidence for this like starting with the
fact that he's under investigation for
alleged sex trafficking and prostitution
of minors you really don't have to go
further than that although to be fair
he's only been accused at this point but
the investigation is well underway and
certainly the evidence against him
continues to mount but as if we needed
another example
here is matt gates chatting it up with
marjorie taylor green on green's podcast
and he makes the case that jamie raskin
who is serving on the january 6th
committee shouldn't be allowed to serve
on the committee because his son died by
suicide not that long ago and the trauma
from that must be clouding his judgment
that's how matt gates put it let's take
a look at the video clip what i worry
about with raskin in all seriousness you
know
when people
encounter
trauma they often associate a lot of the
other things around that trauma with it
even if they don't naturally or or even
rationally associate maybe so and what i
what i worry about for
the congress and for for
jamie raskin you know no one would ever
want to lose a child particularly to
suicide of course as a human being we
actually
our hearts go out to him but yeah i
think that he takes that trauma and he
associates it now with his work in the
congress to such such an interwoven way
that he's unable to kind of do the
congressional experience outside of the
just the dungeon of that personal trauma
and i think it makes him look at
everything in these very like dark and
severe ways where you know we try to
come to the job really to uplift people
to we're here to serve the people well
and we we love this country we're not
here out of a sense of of grievance or
hatred we love america we love it and we
want to vindicate the rights of our
citizens and we want to champion their
causes and battle their dislikes but i
think for jamie raskin it's it's really
like
his service in the congress has almost
become like inextricably
uh attached to this this sad personal
trauma he's had and i think it does
cloud his judgment uh and we could see
that that very darkness and that pain
manifest on on thursday now there's
definitely multiple layers to this story
but i think the main one is that matt
gates really just has to shut his mouth
and not invoke the name of raskin's
deceased son to make a cheap political
point like we know what he's trying to
do with this he makes this disclaimer
about how we're not you know wishing
death on anyone or trauma on anyone
democrat or republican but come on like
we know the point that you're trying to
make here the other layer to all this is
that logically it doesn't really seem to
add up either because plenty of people
experience trauma at some point during
their lifetimes does that mean that they
have to quit their jobs or you know not
participate in certain aspects of their
jobs of course not that doesn't make any
sense and if so like how much trauma is
so much where you're not able to perform
your job responsibilities the whole
thing just doesn't really seem to add up
i don't know why he decided to make this
point to begin with but this also goes
to show that matt gates is probably
worried about the hearings and the
things that
raskin and the other committee members
are going to uncover because we know
that raskin certainly is a force to be
reckoned with and matt gates
probably can tell that the things that
the committee is going to uncover in the
next few weeks is not going to be good
for the trumpian right wing aoc also
responded to this statement for matt
gates with a tweet she said quote rep
raskin is a greater statesman
congressman human being than most of us
history will remember him tommy was a
remarkable person and testament of his
parents love gates is a bad haircut in a
cheap suit a feat of mediocrity given
that he's here on papa's money bye so an
excellent point there from aoc you gotta
wonder if gates regrets this comment
that he made because he really just
doesn't look good he looks dumb and he
also
looks like he's insensitive when it
comes to this stuff so gotta wonder does
he regret it i also kind of get the
sense that he's the kind of person who
would just double down and really not
care that he did wrong and not admit to
doing wrong with this um also during
this appearance matt gates brought up
the idea of giving nancy pelosi a sponge
bath in what was an incredibly weird
moment luke beasley who hosted on friday
he talked about this but i just had to
use this opportunity to play that clip
again let's roll it one more time is he
your least favorite member i have he's
mine i'm on record he's at the top for
me
like i would rather give nancy pelosi a
sponge bath than endure like one dinner
totally but but just to just to bring
this i don't have a color for you okay
like like a lot of people would say
maybe pelosi is their least favorite
member no way
would you trim her i would trim her
toenails with my teeth before i would go
to dinner without him kids again that's
really impressive
so here's how i feel about adam big
yikes there that was an uncomfortable
conversation and probably another
example of something that would have
been better left unsaid during this
marjorie taylor green podcast appearance
and i'm wondering if matt gates is going
to be able to win his primary in august
or if he can win the general election uh
come november because
certainly the first district of florida
is very very conservative but there's
some real accusations against him when
it comes to
this child prostitution and sex
trafficking stuff that i think even many
members of the right wing are not going
to tolerate like if they're given the
option uh in florida in this first
district of voting for
matt gates who is a trumpian republican
and a cartoon character but also has
these allegations against him versus
just another trumpian republican cartoon
character they probably go with the
second one right because there's a lot
less baggage when it comes to that
hypothetical other option that they have
so i'm hoping that this is the last
seven months that matt gates is a
congressman and i hope it comes to an
end for him either because he's facing
some serious criminal charges or because
he loses his re-election bid